Speaker 1: yesterday. I mentioned that today I
was going to talk about the covid mew variant,
which appears to be even more contagious than
the Delta variant. But I want to do something
that I don't think is being properly done. In
many of the headlines that are being written,
it appears as though Mbewe has already lost
to Delta based on the information we have
and that the peak for you already came a month
or two ago. The headlines about MU are the exact
types of headlines you would expect. Disaster
worse than Delta, more contagious than Delta,
potentially looming dystopian situation. But what
you actually have to understand is that it seems
as though the peak of umu has passed and it's
not even going to overtake Delta. So let's look
at a report from the New York Daily News, the
headline similar to many headlines we've seen.
New new new wow. That's tough. New Mbewe
covid variant now found in 49 U.S. states. Oh,
since being discovered in Colombia,
the country of Colombia in January,
that's nine months ago. The MMU variant of covid
has spread to nearly four dozen countries and has
made its presence known in Hawaii and Alaska.
It has so far been found in forty nine states,
with Nebraska being the only state not to have
a detected new variant case. Health officials
believe Mbewe is even more transmissible than
Delta and has the potential to resist vaccines
in the U.S.. It has been in forty nine states
and D.C. California has reported the highest
number of the latest variant, with three eighty
four. One sixty seven were in Los Angeles County.
The identification of variants like Mew and
the spreading of variants around the globe
highlights the need for L.A. County
residents to continue to take measures.
This is why getting vaccinated and protections
are so important. On August 30th, the so called
mbewe a variant of interest due to its ability
to be more transmissible than the other strains
to CDC. I'm sorry the CDC has not yet
made similar classifications about Mbewe,
Fauci says. We are maintaining a close eye on
the new variant, despite it being not at all even
close to becoming dominant in the US. But here is
actually the most important line of the article.
They've buried the lead buried, buried. The U.S.
saw its peak of mbewe variant cases in mid-July,
but case numbers involving that variant have been
declining since. Signaling either a weakening of
the strain or indicating a worrisome future, so
potentially worrisome if something even worse
is replacing it, but this is a really important
detail that is not being included in the sky. Is
falling articles about Mbewe excuse me, it peaked
in July and has been declining. Delta continues
to grow as a percentage of all cases. So when
you look at the articles, more transmissible,
of course, is concerning. Then the question is
what about more deadly? And often it takes a
really long time to get information about that.
You've got to track hospitalization, you've got
to track death rate, et cetera. But it appears as
though we have already passed the MMU peak. Now,
why they say worrisome is if something even
worse is ultimately going to be what knocks out
Delta and becomes dominant. But I actually think
that on this issue, a lot of corporate media have
been spreading a lot of what we call FUD fear,
uncertainty and doubt. We appear to be beyond the
peak of MU. Delta remains dominant. And if we have
growing overall immunity, I'm not going to use the
term herd immunity because we seem to be still far
from that. But if we continue to grow the number
of people with some level of protection Mbewe
to beat Delta, we'll need to find enough people
with no protection in order to start grabbing
a bigger and bigger foothold. So of course,
we watch it. Of course we watch it. But that last
line, Mbewe, appears to already have peaked in
July and is declining, should really be further
up in the articles. And I know dozens of people
have been emailing me about this. And this is
the most important piece of data we have so far
is appears to have peaked in July. Let me know
what you think. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. We will take a break after
the break. Biden's approval continues down,
as we predicted. What's going on?
We'll talk about it in a few moments